[Music]
do you fry a few little parties up here
oh I have actually I've had I've had
some people come up here and we've
cranked up the little jukebox and we've
had some little sit downs in the diner
and we've actually done some little
dancing up here too I love that well if
I'm not on the invite for the next one
I'm going to be angry hello I'm Oliver
travina and this is GQ car collectors
New York I'm in the Bronx about to look
at some amazing cars so stick around
hey car collectors welcome to first in
the waters of the Bronx my name is Noel
come inside and see some of the cars
that I have in my collection we gonna
see the cars and let's see the cars yeah
let's take a look at do it this is a
1956 Chevrolet Bel Air this particular
car is a drop-top
it's got a continental kit on the back
and it also has a 265 engine this
particular car is one of those try five
colors from 1955 56 and 57 and for all
the collectors out there who are into
Bel Air's they want one of those cars
from the tri-five and if you're into Bel
Air and you got one of these little
babies in your collection you're a
really special guy on this side right
here I have the 1968 Chevelle it's red
with a black interior and it's got to
send a console shift and it's got
download wheels this is a really really
hot muscle car it's by date
it's the one I want I'm in love 1956
Volkswagen 23-window bus with a slider
top of him
does it have 23 tiny bags it is ooh
those are mines and I know
did I come with this Idol well they
think they can they can but I've got
them in there because I've always
thought of a Volkswagen bus as being
something happy or that it makes you
happy and so I put them in there to make
it like a happy bus this is a 1962
Chevrolet Impala this particular car has
a really really sweet sweet paint scheme
on it
but if you notice in this particular car
how it has the rounded back that
particular generation within the 1961-62
era there are people who are into the
impalas and they just like that rounded
area in the back of the top there
this looks like it's fresh out of a
movie set I've seen this in the movies
definitely right what is it 1971 Lincoln
Continental Mark 3 so great inches tell
us about you got your protruding grille
you got your flip up lights you got your
power windows your power steering power
brakes and so all of those options were
standard where for most cars that was
something you had to add into the option
package but this is what you call a
survivor car it's as all original paint
and all original interior and all
original top and original engine and is
there any vintage car that you haven't
got but you want to get but you want to
find well next time we see ya we hope
you got no oil thanks for showing us
your cars they are amazing and guys
thanks for checking us out be sure to
subscribe comment below and check out
our episode of car collectors we'll see
you soon
[Music]